il est parti ce matin à 9h22 de la gare
de belfort c'est vraiment une première
parce que cette ligne a été fermée en
1980 de 26 ans plus tard à l'arrêt ouvre
après trois ans de travaux et c'est une
petite révolution ce que de la première
danse est une ligne franco suisse et
deuxièmement il y aura 16 allers retours
par jour entre belfort et delle en
suisse alors à camille sée de ce matin
nous avons rencontré des gens qui
étaient présents dans ce premier train
inaugural en 2018 si en effet la seule
ouverture de ligne en france dernière
réouverture on était haut lieu l'année
dernière et donc c'est extrêmement
important puisque c'est une ligne à la
fois international est à la fois
régionale c'est une bonne chose comme ça
on aura une liaison entre le jura et la
belfort ce qui est dommage que les
trains ne poursuivent pas directement
depuis de léman jusqu'à belfort ville
c'est une très belle chose pour l'avenir
de tout le monde si bien d'un pays à
l'autre pour se déplacer sans prendre de
voiture pour aller dans les grands axes
puis à 10 heures tout à l'heure donc les
deux trains sont arrivés intrants
français et un train suisse ici à
lagardelle et les autorités politiques
des deux pays se sont donc retrouvés sur
le quai de la gare de dell c'est un
moment historique